31 here on a sunday morning now even
with capacity limits here
in las vegas sports books around the
valley are planning for a lot of
football fans yeah bianca holman live at
the west gate with how things are
looking there hi bianca good morning to
you
hey good morning alex good morning john
i'm in the reserved
seating area right now you got to call
in advance to sit over here in these
chairs here but
there are some folks already here 5 30
in the morning y'all
and they've already scoped out their
spot in the front row so if you don't
have a reservation you need to get here
early to
come and get a spot right in front now
even if you plan to watch from home
on your couch you might have placed a
bet on today's game
the chiefs are a three point favorite
that means if they be
if you bet on kansas city they have to
win by four or more
if you want tampa bay to take it all
they have to keep the game within a
field goal for you to cash out
our cameras were here at the west gate
when former las vegas mayor oscar
goodman
made his annual super bowl bet he went a
little unconventional this year take a
look
i'm in this to make a lot of money all
right this is not a game
for me this is serious business so i had
to get a number that i liked
couldn't get the exact number i wanted
for tampa bay so i went with a
proposition bet
i bet that antonio brown will score a
touchdown
and the odds were 2-1
so goodman says he and his wife current
mayor carolyn goodman will watch the
game together tonight
and you bet they'll have lots of great
food and oscar will sip on his some of
his
bombay sapphire gin my favorite as well
to our former mayor and also if you're
not going to be on the overall winner
there's also 400 prop bets that you can
bet on from who will win the coin toss
to how long the national anthem will go
and regardless of how long ago i don't
think anyone will beat whitney houston's
rendition
in 1991 matter of fact they were just
talking about it up there on one of the
big screens so
looking forward to the big game and why
not make a little prop bet here
back to you guys in the studio all right
we need me to profit on how long it
takes bianca to put some real cash money
in on this game
i reckon not too long yeah we'll we'll
see thanks bianca
in just a few minutes so